Patrick Stewart has confirmed we will be
getting a peard movie Welcome to
Sidetrack your saat TV and Movie Channel
so a couple of days ago it was widely
reported that while on the happy sad
confused podcast Patrick Stewart has
confirmed that there is a script for a
new peard movie or at very least a movie
that peard is involved in which I think
is going to be quite
important and that Patrick Stewart is
actually now seeing the script at the
point of filming the podcast which was
back in November while he was basically
talking to lots of people about his
Memoir he was asked about a possibility
of peard movie and he confirmed that yes
there was a script at the time he hadn't
seen it but he said in the podcast he
was going to be seeing it in the next
few weeks so this was filmed back in
November we can assume he's seen it by
now and that he was actually really
excited about the possibility he
actually talked about um the Star Trek
movies he did following um TNG and how
he said they were of varying quality yes
yes they were and how first Contact was
the best yeah that's also correct and
that he talked about Jonathan Frank's
directing that and how much of an
influence Jonathan Franks had had on him
during the process of creating Star Trek
so I spoke to those industry insiders
that I do get to talk to and found out
as much as I could about the planned
Project B I am told that Paramount has
at least a five-year plan for Star Trek
at all times they know roughly what
they're doing with Star Trek up to five
years into the future they know what
they're doing with Star Trek Legacy
already and they know what not just the
next Paramount plus TV movie is they
have a very good idea what the movie
after that will be as well so obviously
section 31 is going into filming about
now they know that the next streaming
movie will be this Picard movie and they
have a rough idea what the movie F that
will be
too they know when Legacy is coming and
they know how many seasons of strange
New World their Planet if you're
enjoying the video don't forget to like
subscribe and hit that Bell notification
so you miss none of our new videos and
most importantly leave a comment it's a
community after all we want to know what
you think too One Source actually said
to me it would be massively incompetent
for them not to do that and that all
Studios when they have
like this at least consider a five maybe
even a 10-year plan but that that plan
can be flexible it can change because
things in the movie industry do change
for example the Michelle yo plan section
31 originally was going to be a series
and then a miniseries and then they came
up with the move the idea basically
because Michelle yo was still Keen to do
it so because of the changing situation
mainly Michelle yo winning an Oscar and
becoming very very big busy they changed
the plan and came up with this new idea
of these straight to Paramount plus
streaming movies now the section 31
movie roughly has a budget of around
$130 million and is going to be more
like a double episode than an actual
cinematic movie but Star Trek have been
making NE Cinema quality episodes for
quite some time now at least visually so
them spending a little bit more money
it's basically what three episodes of
Star Trek would cost roughly a little
bit more um by adding a little bit more
money they can up that quality a touch
so that's what they're doing with
section 31 are they going to be doing
the same with peard well I'm being told
at the moment that is the plan that it
will be a straight to Paramount plus
movie that this will be actually a Next
Generation movie and that really you're
going to see something a lot more along
the lines of Picard season 3 than peard
seasons one and two now why do I think
that is how they're going to do it well
for one the popularity of season 3
clearly but also Patrick Stewart is is
an older man I think he's
83 and the strain of actually producing
a basically what would be an action
sci-fi movie maybe a little bit more
than he can handle he needs other actors
there that can support him and we have
those actors there gagging to do this
we've seen Marina certis and Gates
mcfaden both talk about how they would
love to come back to a TNG project if
the fans want it they were teasing us
with this movie idea anything up to 18
months ago because Paramount planned it
18 months ago but could this plan change
as I say it's flexible well clearly
there is a lot going on at Paramount at
the moment there is a sale being
discussed or a merger with Warner
Brothers apparently I am hearing rumors
nonconfirmed that actually Apple are
involved in that conversation at the
moment and they'd be quite interested in
buying at least the studio portion of
Paramount if Paramount is carved up as
some business insiders are talking about
and how that situation UNF falls in the
next 12 months really could change a lot
so when could we actually see this peard
movie well if a script is completed now
I'm being told that the plan for
Michelle Yo's section 31 for that to
appear on our screens roughly by the
summer of this year it's now going to be
appearing in the winter it's been pushed
back thanks to the strikes but the peard
movie would basically follow it quite
quickly we might actually see that on
our screens by the end of
2025 the original plan was again for
these movies to come every two years but
that plan may have been accelerated
slightly at least in part because of
Bard's age but also because they want to
take advantage of the popularity of
peard season 3 they want that momentum
to carry on and to follow through with a
new peard film also my source is saying
that this would be a precursor to Legacy
in some way now that is only his opinion
I should say he's saying that he that's
the only way he sees Legacy getting kick
started now which would mean we may get
to see the Enterprise G in this new
movie now that would also make sense
because obviously none of the crew of
The Next Generation have their own
Starship knocking about so if there is
some sort of issue or Mission they need
to go on doesn't it only make sense that
they're going to call on seven that
Picard will call on his son and the
Enterprise G will come flying to their
aid at very least maybe the end of that
movie and that that could be then used
to catapult the new Legacy series I
think that is a plan that makes sense
and it would also make sense in why this
movie isn't going to be two years after
section 31 but only 12 months they will
want to follow that movie as closely as
possible with a new series of Legacy the
chances are the movie will film and then
Legacy will start filming almost
immediately after that and it takes
around eight or nine months from filming
to actually our screens so what do I
think about them coming back with a TNG
movie for one if it is a TNG movie and
not aard movie I think that has way more
legs on it and I think it'll be way more
popular
I think seasons one and two of peard
struggled at least in part because of
Patrick Stewart's age he is an old man
um he's still a phenomenally good actor
but there is the limitation to what an
80-year old man can do in an action
Sci-Fi series I think when we had the
rest of the characters and we had that
Nostalgia of this third series and you
had actors that he could lean on you
know Jonathan Franks can do a bit more
of the action stuff etc etc then it did
make for a better
series main reason why season 3 was much
better though was because it was written
much better and it was conceived better
but you know for card's age as well and
finally one last little thing I have to
add I am being told that the chances are
peard is going to die in this series and
that it will be actually the last time
we ever get to see Jean Luke peard in
any Star Trek what do you think of that
get into the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
do appear first finally go to c.co which
is our dedicated website where we do
articles based on most of our videos and
we try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest go check
it out as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time now that also
would make sense and make logical sense
if if you consider
how consider
[Music]
consider